الى كارمن جو خضار عبر الهاتف
مراسله الجزيره من دوناتسك اذا كارمن
مقابل استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه لثامن
بلده القوات الروسيه تعلن ان سيطرت على
بلده نوفو دونيسك في مقاطعه
وتعلن ايضا استمرار صدها
للهجمات الاوكرانيه ماذا في التفاصيل
نعم حسن في
مخصنياتك اليوم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قالت
ان هناك سيطره كامله على هذه المنطقه التي
تقع عند على مقربه من الحدود بين مقاطعه
ومقاطعه وهذا يعني ويدلل على ان خط القتال
الذي يبدا في شمال مقاطعه
التحديد يمتد ويصل الى تلك المناطق في عند
المتاخمه وبطبيعه الحال الى جابولوجيا
نفسها هذه المقاطعه اليوم الحديث يجري من
قبل المواقع العسكريه وهنا نقف امام تعارض
في الروايات بين
الروايه الاوكرانيه والروايه الروسيه اذ
ان المواقع العسكريه نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه
التي قالت اوكرانيا انها ضمتها
انه لم تجري السيطره عليها وتقول ان هناك
كرا وان التحديث شاهدت قتالا في الايام
الماضيه قتالا مستعدا وهي تقع ضمن هذه
المنطقه الرماديه الواقعه بين ملتقى
السيطره القوات الروسيه ومنطقه سيطرات
القوات الاوكرانيا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تتحدث باستمرار عن صدرها هجمات لناحيه
دانيال المدينه وحتى جنوبيه تتحدث عن
مارينكا والمعارك فادار التي تجري فيها
المعطيات الوارده من شمال مدينه يسكو ان
هناك محاولات من قبل القوات الروسيه
للتقدم للجنوب غرب هذه المنطقه وايضا
الحديث قبل قليل من قبل وزاره الدفاع
الطبي هجومي لاوكرانيين في محيطي مدينه
باخمه سوليدار اذا ما كل هذه المعطيات وما
تورده المواقع العسكريه حسن
تدلل هذه المعطيات وفقه هذه المواقع
العسكريه اننا ازاء مرحله ثانيه من هذا
الهجوم المضاده الذي كان قد بدا في الرابع
من حزيران يوني يتحدثون في هذه المرحله عن
ان المعطى الاساس والمتغير الميداني هو
دخول جبهه خرسون هذه المقاطعه الجنوبيه
الى جبهات القتال خرسون خرجت من المعادله
بعد تطهير سد نوفكا ومع الحصار المياه
وجفاف التربه في تلك المنطقه اليوم يجري
الحديث عن محاولات اوكرانيه
لابتياز انها دينيترو وايضا قبل ايام كان
هناك وحتى تكثفت هذه المحاولات يوم امس تم
الحديث عن استهدافه عصري محاولات اوكرانيه
لاجتياز نهر في تلك المنتخبات التحديد
ايضا هناك حديثات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
الخرسون وربما حسن بع جال المعطى الاساس
اليوم واسترداد القوات الاوكرانيه لمدينه
بولنداخه الواقعه في مقاطعه هذا يدلل على
ان هناك مسعى لمد هذا الخط الواصل الى
مدينه مريوط الجنوبيه كانت قد شهدت قتالا
في بدايه هذه الحرب واليوم هذا المعطى
وهذا الاستهداف الذي ادى الى سقوط ضحايا
دليل على ان المعارك ستستعر في مقبل
الايام شكرا
من دونيتسك